hello I am Raphael Bennett I am a
postdoc at the analytical research and
development department at Merck in the
Rahway site and today I would like to
talk to you about my current exploits
with supercritical fluid chromatography
specifically with the newer
pharmaceutical modalities and let's get
started so some of the newer modalities
in the pharmaceutical industry have
included carbohydrates nucleotides
peptides proteins polymers and bio
conjugates
now these analytes are very diverse in
structure many of them hydrophilic and
usually one form of chromatography
doesn't cover everything so it's
important to have experts in all
different forms of chromatography
despite the fact that usually you have
reverse phase chromatography as your
go-to but or more polar analytes um our
PLC tends to not be the best way to go
sometimes to pick up the slack on this
you have things like hydrophilic
interaction chromatography however if
you're doing purification as you would
tend to do in the pharmaceutical
industry
heylook methods are oftentimes difficult
to scale furthermore if you have more
charged analytes that you want to deal
with you have ion exchange methods which
are very nice as far as using oftentimes
an aqueous type mobile phases but
because you have non-volatile salts
involved these methods are oftentimes
not mass spectrometry friendly and for
purification purposes you may have an
additional and desalting step so one of
the methods for purification oftentimes
used is supercritical fluid
chromatography to address these concerns
so the supercritical fluid
chromatography generally involves the
use of compressed co2 as part of the
mobile phase what this enables is high
mass transfer kinetics and faster flow
rates which means that you'll have
faster analytical methods and this
translates to faster purification which
can help you with in terms of cost
savings in terms of less liquid solvent
usage because a lot of your liquid
solvent is steady tap as co2 therefore
faster purification and reduced waste so
usually a greener method however
supercritical fluid chromatography when
it first began using pure co2 it's the
mobile phase was restricted to the two
nonpolar analytes as time went on and
technology grew you had the introduction
of modifiers usually alcoholic in nature
that would be very miscible with the co2
mobile phase these modifiers as you go
along to more polar analytes would
include additives sometimes water these
additives could be acidic or basic but
some polar entity that enables a better
separation however peptides proteins and
nucleic acids nucleotides still to this
day present a problem for SFC that many
researchers are still trying to find
answers to so with that in mind I will
talk about the polar modalities I have
encountered and answers in which I have
found or addressing each of these
including carbohydrates nucleotides
peptides and proteins and for that last
section I will go and delve a little
deeper into the relevance of using SOC
for these separations and purification
so for carbohydrates one of the methods
I've used for this is enhanced with
fluidity liquid chromatography otherwise
known as EF LC e f LC is used on SMC
instrumentation but the idea is that you
tend to use a higher modifier then you
would typically find SFC traditional SFC
methods use v the 50% modifier often
with methanol for polarity and the idea
is that as you have more
modifier you have higher pressure but
you exchanged that for higher illusion
strength meaning that for more polar
compounds the higher modifier enables
the illusion and therefore separation of
those analytes now in somewhat recent
times people have been more exploring
the use of methanol water combinations
to get even more solvent strength
however along with this you have even
more higher pressure to deal with so and
in addition to that not all proportions
of methanol water and co2 are miscible
and so you have to keep in mind that you
have to keep in mind the exact
proportions in which you mix for mobile
phase when you plan to use them however
if you're aware of the de mixing region
and you know where to use methanol water
and co2 you can exact decent separations
of polar molecules like sugars as shown
in the example below now the FLC has
been used many times in the analytical
scale but recently I published a paper
where we showed an example of using it
in the prep reduce Cal for purification
much like you would expect for hillock
style or SFC style of purification what
tends to happen is that the sample day
you went is very importantly solvent in
which you dissolve your sample prior to
injection is very important to the kind
of peak shape and the amount of bloating
that you can use on a particularly sized
column what you would expect is that as
you have higher organic content in your
dil youant you can usually load more and
you have better peak shape however in
the event that you are using EF LC you
are likely dealing with compounds that
are relatively hydrophilic or polar and
therefore you might find that it's
actually better to use a more aqueous or
even pure water dil you went and instead
leverage
low sample volume and high concentration
because you have higher solubility of
your analyte and aqueous a more aqueous
medium so it's important to keep in mind
that if you use EF LC for the purpose of
scale to realize that there is some
fine-tuning to do with sample WN
furthermore based off of this work with
privative purification in EF LC we
demonstrated that the method that
developed was fully amenable to mass
directed purification now this is very
important for us to see in that for HPLC
mass directed purification has been
around for some time
but in SFC it's still a it's still
instrumentation that it's not quite it's
not quite Universal and so it was very
impressive to see if they'll see a new
method be completely amenable with mass
directed purification what's good about
this is that you you can look you can
detect anomalies so if you can't see the
molecule or analyte of interest in UV
you can leverage the mass spec or for
triggering a purification furthermore
because you have a confirmed identity a
very selective identity of the analyte
of interest this allows some flexibility
of for separations that may not be a
robust meaning retention time is
shifting as you as you perform
subsequent runs and so with a master
activated system you can account for
this and furthermore because you have a
selective detector you can be sure that
what you are collecting is in fact the
analyte of interest so with EF LC we are
able to use mass directed purification
workflow now I will shift gears towards
another polar set of molecules
nucleotides and pharmaceutical analogs
now nucleotides are known to be very
troublesome in SOC and they continue to
be to this day
and you can kind of see that as you look
at the chemical structure of nucleotides
you start with a simple nucleobase
nucleobases can usually be separated
fairly easily on even just traditional
silica column using a methanol modifier
however when you add the carbohydrate
and turn that into a nucleoside you you
will find that you can still use SFC
style
conditions but a little water goes a
long way as far as improving peak shake
now when you add the phosphate group to
and you have nucleotides that you're
dealing with like adenosine
monophosphate your peak shape becomes
terrible and you have a lot of trouble
loading and so even with the strategy we
use for carbohydrates earlier using high
modifier and high amounts of water in
that methanolic modifier you still don't
have the peak shape necessary to have a
good analytical method or a good
preparators method so recently and
another patient that if you specifically
have a combination of methanol water and
ammonium hydroxide that's finely tuned
for the sake of SFC purification or
analytical scale methods you can
actually allude and separate nucleotides
i mean particularly a pharmaceutical
analogues with these nucleotide but we
took this even so far as to show a
preparatory r where we were able to
obtain the nucleotide of interest i
would like to also mention that there is
a known EF LC analytical method for
separating nucleobases new--this sorry
nucleosides and nucleotides however this
method does require the use of sodium
phosphate buffer so the next class of
molecules I'd like to talk about the
last one is peptides and proteins and I
would like to further delve into
particularly the effective SOC on global
conformation when looking at these
molecules so proteins and peptides again
covering their first
set of molecules which are all
constructed of amino acids but they can
have different levels of hydrophobicity
hydrophilicity they can have post
translational modification and
altogether be very complex molecules in
addition um you have another form of
structure to deal with higher order
structure that you typically don't see
with small molecules and this is
particularly important for the
pharmaceutical industry industry where
um you you we need drugs to remain
active after purification and part of
that activity oftentimes is related to
the confirmation of that protein
unfortunately SFC in today's literature
is known to cause protein denaturation
however is important to look at is the
denaturation caused by SFC reversible
perhaps um and there are many reasons
for instance that would cause SOC 2 to
denature protein namely could be
exposure to co2 two of the exposure to
high pressure and in general exposure to
an environment that is unlike what the
protein would normally see in its native
form so i'll go over a little history on
the separation of peptides and proteins
one of the fountains that one of the
determining works that showed that SFC
could be applied to peptides was done by
taylor terry taylor and co-workers and
in this case he showed that if you use
pure methanol as your modifier you
generally had very very very poor peak
shape unusable for analytical method
method design and if you added some
trifluoroacetic acid particularly anion
bearing agent you had much much better
peak shape that made SOC a viable
technique later to this I published a
paper using EF LC and mass spectrometry
in which I separated many peptides and
proteins going even as large as 80 kilo
daltons for transferring protein that is
also fairly polar I again
I used a methanol water a combination
with high modifier in order to exact
this kind of separation now when looking
at this EF lcms method i particularly
tried to probe whether the protein was
likely denatured or not and there was a
couple ways to look into this with a
protein as it goes to a mass spec it is
ionized and if it's folded or native
typically the charge envelope that you
would see is on the low side whereas if
you have a unfolded protein there is
more protons ionizable protons exposed
that can now be ionized by the mass spec
and therefore you'll have a higher
charge envelope in addition you can
track to see if the mass of the original
protein is preserved so that the protein
is in fact intact in my work we had
determined that for the select example
shown here
transferring cytochrome c the proteins
were intact but the charge states were
rather high indicating that there was
likely some unfolding involved now
fast-forward into a project at Merck and
we wanted to look at the use of SFC for
the sake of protein purification in this
case we devised a generic method for all
the peptides and proteins we tested
using a two Pico Lilla beam column to
centimeter prep and a special blend of
mobile phase in which the modifier was a
three to one methanol associate or nitro
ratio with of course using water and TFA
to enable good Pichet the idea here is
that we have a fast high cycle time bar
rather low cycle time method in which we
would expose the protein to actual
purification conditions so the idea here
is during a subsea pyrrha fication would
the unfolding that would most likely
happen be reversible for the proteins
and peptides that we wanted to test we
had these five analytes
starting with bradykinin which is a
peptide with no order and therefore what
we put into the SFC instrument would
likely be the same as what we would get
out versus myoglobin which is a much
more complex protein and may be
susceptible to donation during SFC
purification so one of the ways in which
you can you can probe for protein
conformation is circular dichroism now
this is the oftentimes viewed as the
gold standard for determining protein
conformation and they can look at
different secondary structures alpha
helixes Bettie beta sheets and random
random coil formation and in this case
we had all of our five peptides and
proteins checked both pre and post
purification as shown in the the read
further after PFC purification and the
black before purification the idea here
being that the profile should be roughly
the same if a protein or peptide is not
modified after purification in this case
all the peptides and proteins that had
order to begin with seem to lose that
order except for insulin which according
to our theoretical helical calculation
seemed to mostly preserve its its its
protein structure basically based on
this kind of analysis I will point out
Apple myoglobin is is though the
calculation shows a some difference that
this difference is slight um and would
oftentimes need to be verified by some
other method and furthermore even though
C D spectra at a particular solvent and
temperature can usually indicate that
protein conformation is similar it does
not necessarily guarantee that the
protein conformation is the same so for
this reason we have C D temper
temperature hysteresis analysis and in
in this form of probing what we do is we
have
protein sample that we heat up subject
to heat and we watch the protein unfold
and take measurements at every
temperature and then we have the protein
cool and this causes some refolding of
that protein um in perhaps a reversible
or irreversible way but the idea is if
you have two protein samples that are
the same then it should unfold and
refold in the same manner as you elevate
temperature and decrease temperature in
this example again insulin was the only
analyte which seemed to maintain its
secondary structure and just to bring
the focus over to Apple myoglobin you
can now more clearly see that the pre
and post purification protein has in
fact changed structure based off of this
analysis now the third way in which you
can look at protein conformation is
using a technique that we've developed
in our labs called size exclusion
chromatography hydrogen deuterium
exchange analysis now the idea with this
that you have a protein that has
ionizable protons and you can put this
protein in a deuterium oxide solvent
which allows you to do to rate these
ionizable protons and from a deuterated
protein you can then expose the protein
to size exclusion chromatography which
has a protic solvent used in it and the
protons in this protic solvent BAC
exchange with the deuterons on a
deuterated protein the idea here is that
a more unfolded protein will have more
due duration sites available for proton
BAC exchange and therefore you can
distinguish between a more and less
folded protein using the concept of
delta h DX which is basically the
difference
in molecular weight between a underrated
proton undoped rated protein and a
proton back exchanged protein from the
difference between these two you can
tell which one is more folded by the
idea that the more folded protein
because it has less ionizable less
ionizable protonation sites should have
more deuterons contained within it and
therefore the delta HDX should be higher
for that more folded protein and
conversely a protein that is more
unfolded will have the lower HDX so for
the same reason that you look at you
look at temperature changes in
temperature hysteresis analysis or
circular dichroism you would look at
temperature dependent HDX analysis just
to make sure that you have the same
profile between two protein samples in
particular from from this analysis we
can see that again myoglobin clearly has
different structure both for and after
purification before purification in
black again and the post purification in
read an interesting our situation that
we detect with myoglobin is that in fact
we see a higher Delta HDX which doesn't
mean that the protein is necessarily
more native but it does mean that the
protein is or compact or most likely
based off of this Delta HDX reading of
these again insulin is the only peptide
analyte that actually seem to maintain
its secondary structure or its global
structure throughout this whole analysis
and so the sec HDX data corroborates the
ECD and also data that we had determined
from the previous work so in conclusion
I hope I've convinced you
SFC can be used for a variety of
applications including the more polar
novel pharmaceutical applications that
we're seeing now furthermore a SOC can
be used with protein therapeutic
molecules but should be carefully probed
for the sake of seeing if conformation
changes during purification therefore
it's a profile 'ti of an SMC
purification method I'd also like to
mention that of the methods that you can
use for probing si si HDX certainly a
method as effective for determining
protein structure after SFC purification
however it would be best in order to use
all methods for presented here for the
sake of determining protein conformation
and for that as a visual example of this
I present to you the six men and the
elephant or the sake of saying that each
of these blind men represented here for
the different techniques and give you a
certain perspective of the conformation
that you're trying the state but
together you can verify a whole picture
of protein conformation analysis and
with that I would like to acknowledge my
fellow co-workers who work with me on
this research at Merck I'd also like to
thank my sponsor and the mrl post
doctoral program who have made this
research possible I'd also like to thank
my former mentor dr. Susan ELISA from
the Ohio State University for pioneering
her work in enhanced fluidity liquid
chromatography and lastly I'd like to
acknowledge my post doctoral mentor Eric
L regalado
thank you and I'll take any questions